what's the advice or what are the
principles to like upskilling yourself
in the new market that you're in in
terms of recruitment right recruitment's
recruitment so whether you're doing
recruitment in the uk or you're doing
recruitment in the us fundamentally like
in my opinion the principles of the
things that you need to do to be
successful are the same now there are
naturally nuances so nuances would be
you know you're not going to work a job
with a client unless you've signed a
contract with them because contract law
in the us is everything so we measure
success you know when we're not doing
deals with how many clients are we
signing up and that's because if they
haven't got a contract signed they don't
have to pay you yeah basically yeah it's
a leading indicator for us as to whether
or not we're winning but i think the the
biggest thing and the thing that you
need to do before you do anything else
is just go and talk to some candidates i
was pretty open with a lot of people
like i said to people look i'm a
recruiter i just moved here from the uk
i've just started this new market i'd
love to chat with you and just
understand a bit about you know ask you
a couple of questions about the market
the best way to learn is getting on the
phone in my opinion be vulnerable be
open to learning and just be honest with
people we teach people how to have a
good first conversation with someone
without having to know everything about
the market and by them saying hey tell
me a bit about what your biggest
challenge is day to day that person who
asks that question learns something not
only about the candidate but about their
industry the recruitment mentors podcast
is proudly sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker